As we enter into 1917,
the United States
has been able to maintain
its neutrality in World War
I. In fact, President Wilson
has just won a re-election based
on the platform that
he kept us out of war.
And to large degree, he was
able to keep the US out of war
because the German
Empire had pulled back
from its unrestricted
submarine warfare.
After the sinking
of the Lusitania
and how angered
America had gotten,
they said, OK, we're
not going to attack
passenger vessels anymore.
We're only going to attack
things that are definitely
British, non-passenger vessels.
But as we go into January
1917, the British blockade
on the Central Powers
was having its effect.
And the Central Powers
were getting desperate,
in particular Germany.
And so they are eager
to essentially do
the same to the British.
Once again, go with the
unrestricted submarine warfare.
But the Germans
knew that if they
were to go back to this, that
it's likely that the US would
enter the war on the
side of the Allies.
So knowing that was
likely to happen.
They said, well, how
could we slow the US down.
And the thinking was, well,
maybe we could somehow
enlisted the help of
Mexico which at the time
was not the best terms
with the United States.
And so Arthur Zimmerman who was
the German Foreign Secretary,
the equivalent of the United
States Secretary of State.
The Foreign Minister,
Arthur Zimmerman
sends an encoded a
telegram to the Mexicans.
And it's encoded,
especially because it
has to go over lines that are
controlled by the Americans.
And in it, he actually
proposes an alliance
to slow the Americans down.
So this is what he wrote.
So this is a coded telegram.
And then, it was
actually intercepted
by British intelligence
and decoded and then shared
with the Americans,
and then that
was also then made public
to the American public.
And so this is why it's
fascinating to actually read
this stuff.
This is January 1917.
This is the Germans
talking to the Mexicans.
"We intend to begin on
the first of February
unrestricted submarine warfare.
We shall endeavor
in spite of this
to keep the United States
of America neutral.
In the event of
this not succeeding,
we make Mexico a
proposal alliance
on the following basis--
make war together, make peace
together, generous financial
support, and an understanding
on our part that Mexico
is to reconquer the lost
territory in Texas, New
Mexico, and Arizona.
The settlement in
detail is left to you.
You will inform the
President--" they're
talking about the
president of Mexico.
"--of the above most secretly
as soon as the outbreak of war
with the United States of
America is certain and add
the suggestion that he
should, on his own initiative,
invite Japan to immediate
adherence and at the same time
mediate between
Japan and ourselves.
Please call the President's
attention to the fact
that the ruthless
employment of our submarines
now offers the prospect
of compelling England
in a few months to make peace.
Signed Zimmerman."
Now, the Mexicans,
when they read this,
they really didn't
take it too seriously.
They didn't think that
they could seriously
engage the US in a war.
They couldn't
seriously take back
or occupy these territories.
So they didn't really
think much of it.
The real effect of
this telegram was
to make the American
public angry.
They were going to go back
into the unrestricted submarine
warfare.
And the Germans, themselves,
talk about ruthless-- "ruthless
employment of our
the submarines."
So when people talk about,
what were the causes.
What brought the US into war?
The ones that are
typically cited
are the unrestricted
submarine warfare.
The sinking of the Lusitania.
The Zimmerman telegram
that was trying
to get Mexico to somehow
get into a war with the US
and reclaim these territories.
And as we'll see, a
few months after this,
the US actually does
declare war on Germany
and enter into World War I.